I think it's always more fun having the
conservative guests and having that back
and forth and in fact that's what makes
I think the show work I agree with you
about labels but I noticed you're
sitting in front of a billboard that
says runaway slave I don't have time to
go through all of his lies we only have
an hour I think you're a great guy I
really hope you lose your next election
because I think your colossal E wrong on
a number of things but if exactly this
if I if I band around to disagree know
who I thought was colossal II wrong I
would be talking to myself I think it's
important especially when you think
someone is dangerous to expose that to
as many people as you can so giving
someone like Milo or Alex Jones or Ann
Coulter a platform that's a public
service you said after 9/11 what we
should do is attack Muslim countries
kill their leaders and convert them to
Christianity yeah you still you still
stand by that I love people who stick by
their guns even when the crowd does not
agree I do think that there is an
element of racism against what
individuals I do I do see the
conservative another Trump person let me
just say this that's absurd
the Pope made a very strong statement in
support of my position on climate change
not yours and your position when you
heard that was hey let's leave the
science to the scientists okay first of
all you're not doing that but second of
all I am you're not because 97% of all
scientists believe a bogus number it's
so not a bogus it's so yours is mine as
yours is mine
this show like none other provides an
opportunity to articulate deeply held
beliefs cherished ideas in the face of
people who are radically skeptical about
them having me on the show to present
the other side but not every network
does that all the time it might be the
only place in the world where we'd ever
meet everyone knows that he gives people
room to breathe and he gives people
their time to talk and make their point
and he will give you your space to do
that but then when I look at the
Democrats use you see who's up against
this guy this unbelievably useless
terrible candidate of Hillary Clinton I
feel liberated to say whatever I believe
and some of that is not very popular
I've gotten booed several times by the
audience bill is clearly someone who is
a liberal boy he's not a party-line guy
you don't do your political viewpoint
Party ideology any service if you assume
they were always right
you